It's great to welcome back today, Peter Joseph,
who's the founder of the Zeitgeist movement
and director and writer of the film Inter
Reflections, of course, based on his book.
Peter, it's so great to have you back on.
Thank you, David.
I appreciate you having me.
Happy doing well.
So I'm curious.
So much has happened over the last four years
and in particular over the last couple of
weeks, really since the November election
with, you know, literally dozens and dozens
of events that previously we would imagine
to be extraordinarily unlikely in the United
States.
I'm curious on a few different levels.
Number one, based on your analysis and the
perspective that you've talked about on our
program before, that you have about the way
the United States is organized, are the events
of the last few weeks that that unlikely or
is it exactly the type of thing that your
perspective would would suggest is inevitable
in some sense?
Well, the specifics are hard to pinpoint,
but this kind of right wing insurrection coming
from what I feel is many, many generations
of lower class oppression isn't necessarily
unpredictable.
You know, the there's this kind of a short
term picture and a long term picture, as with
anything when it comes to to the human condition
in terms of causality and human behavior.
So on one side, if you look at the events
of January 6th, you have this rather sparse
insurrection, so to speak, kind of a satire
of a coup, if you will, if you really kind
of look at it when they stormed the capital.
And then you relate that clearly to a figurehead
that has deep cult of personality and has
been promoting things in his self-interest
with no responsibility.
And people have flocked to him and they believed
him.
And this is where we end up.
So that's one perspective.
I don't think you can just blame, for example,
Donald Trump explicitly.
Donald Trump came from somewhere.
He was a manifestation of something.
I mean, if you look at his character in and
of himself, he represents really a kind of
kind of extreme caricature of what capitalist
society is.
Right.
It's really about people.
I mean, he's really groomed into this since
his father's time and he knows how to angle
he a professional angler.
And there's a there's a line there with morality
where someone goes from being a good businessman
to being effectively a criminal.
And I think there's debate as to how gray
that area is when you're dealing with exploitation
and gaming, because that's what our society
is.
We're gaming.
That's what people do.
That's the only theory that really supports
the kind of behavior that our economy does
is game theory, as people have modeled in
the past in terms of who will be successful
and who will not.
So there's that.
So you have that kind of character that comes
from society and that on the other side you
have people.
And again, it's sad because people become
so upset when they look at these images and
they see the they see it effectively, a kind
of domestic terrorist heir to this right wing
insurgency obsessed with conspiracies.
They don't believe anything.
It's easy to be upset with those people, but
they have they came from somewhere.
There's a reason why they have evolved to
where they've become.
And it's not just Donald Trump.
As I said before, I think this society in
America due to socioeconomic inequality is
something that we spoke about years ago in
my book, The New Human Rights Movement.
It's the core focus of that book.
Socioeconomic inequality is one of the largest
drivers of destabilization than anything.
It is it is the ultimate precondition, so
to speak, sociologically that forces people
into a kind of antagonism.
Even in a wealthy society such as the United
States, the haves and the have nots have become
so severe throughout the years.
And people to understand why they understand
the mechanics, they understand the history,
they start to feel, they start to feel like
they're left behind.
So as bizarre as it is that you have a white
culture in America that now feels they're
oppressed, given the true history of America,
where obviously the white man particularly
is far from the most oppressed, but this is
manifest from this what I believe, class inequality.
And I think there's a great deal of sociological
research, epidemiological study that supports
that.
So for me, the solution to all of this is
to create more economic equality.
Ultimately, that's really the most critical
thing society can do at this point to help
it stop the instability that I think is only
going to keep growing at many different levels
from the standpoint of, well, I'll frame this
up in a slightly different way and get get
your thoughts on it.
Whenever we we've seen over the last four
years the next high bar of crazy reached,
sometimes there will be this feeling of, OK,
this is now over the line and nobody is going
to be OK with this.
And then we hear, oh, actually, there's people
who are OK with it.
And then you see the social media posts and
then you see the short memory that that many
have for these sorts of things.
And you see the way that the media apparatus
sort of creates an environment where no matter
what takes place, some.
One is there that you can point to that will
actually say this is actually OK or defended
in some way, and we could if we say what was
the origin of this, we could come up with
a lot of different starting points.
But in terms of the political media landscape,
I often think back to the Reagan welfare queen
meme of this imaginary woman who's having
all these kids and getting rich off of it
and has a Cadillac.
And like once you believe that, then you go
into immigrants are dangerous and then you
go into trickle down economics or whatever.
Right.
Like fill in the blanks and then you get to
Hugo Chavez and Dominion and whatever stole
the election, like the ultimate caricature
that we heard over the last couple of months.
Is that a fair way to talk about the history
and that that makes it about a 35 year history,
or would you kind of frame it up in a different
way?
Well, I think that you're touching upon how
to things how belief systems come to be and
belief system share share excuse me, a common
architecture.
So going back to Reagan, Thatcher and the
rise of neo liberalism, where Thatcher, I
believe her quote was there is no society.
She's all about the individual.
And this sort of narcissistic, righteous self
individualism came forward that clearly has
been deeply caustic.
And if you believe things like, well, you
get what you work for or you just have to
pull yourself up by your bootstraps, if you
believe that people have complete free will
and it's all up to them, which is that general
gesture of all of this, then you're going
to not care very much about people that are
actually suffering legitimately because of
the very structure of the system to not have
the same advantages that other people do because
of the long, long generation of inequality
in many facets of that.
But, yeah, I agree with you.
Absolutely.
It's it's in the book I remember writing a
whole section on how the kind of wing mindset
can be created and how, particularly from
that standpoint, how this if you like, for
example, if you believe that you get what
you work for, then you probably also believe
that people that commit crime have absolutely
total responsibility.
Forget they're there in poverty, forget what
their life condition was.
So you end up with that kind of distorted
value system based on narrow individualism.
And I think that also is very much part of
this society because of the economic system
once again.
So my causality, as you know, David, it's
really all about what our economy has done
to us sociologically and obviously psychologically.
And if you have people that are stuck in a
system, regardless of the reality of our condition,
regardless of our potentials for, say, post
scarcity, and they're fighting with each other
because of the structure, not because we have
to, but because of the structure, you're going
to have antagonism, you're going to have racism.
You're going to have all this group versus
group stuff.
You see it microcosms, you see it macrocosmic.
I was on another podcast the other day and
I was reminded that in West Virginia I'm from
the South and I had friends, a friend of a
friend from West Virginia, and they were describing
to me something surreal and how in West Virginia
before NAFTA, the south and the north actually
were at odds because of economic strife.
If you can believe that, just like you saw
it, you see in Italy, in the north and south
historically as well, which also generated
mob stuff.
But it wasn't until NAFTA came along and jobs
were taken by people in the global south that
people started to hate people from the global
south.
They started to hate Mexicans.
So you see that antagonism as well.
So that's a good corollary.
So one of the calls related to this that I
get frequently recently when I when I hear
from my audience is how do we fix this?
And one of the reactions I've had is if we
grant that it's taken 30 to pick the Reagan
Thatcher example, 35, 40 years to get into
this, it would be unreasonable to expect that
in a two, four or six year period of time
we would get out of it.
And some of the things that have to be changed
are, on the one hand, as you're talking about,
the sort of structure of the financial system
and inequality.
On the other hand, I when people ask me, how
can I convince my aunt that she's wrong, I
think that that's that's what we might call
a retail strategy and we could have that conversation.
But it's less relevant to the fact that you
probably need a decade or longer of cultural
and an economic and educational change to
really start changing these things.
It would other than by dictatorship, I don't
know how you achieve the type of change that
has taken place over 40 years in a short period
of time.
I, I certainly can sympathize with that sentiment.
I would say on a certain level, the cultural
shifts required, particularly when it comes
to something like racism, which I do believe
could subside greatly in this country and
beyond, it would take more than that because
racism has a snowball effect.
Racism started as a as a legal construct where
in excuse me, the slavery period in early
America.
And many people don't realize this, the indentured
servants that were imprisoned.
In Europe, they were taken over here, they
used for about seven years and they could
be free, that was not the best business investment
from the standpoint of the plantation owners.
And they started to learn about the African
transatlantic slave trade, where the kings
in Africa were kidnaping their own people
and literally selling them to the Dutch and
other other slave ships.
And they were brought over to America as a
new investment.
But the fact that these people had black skin
had no relevance.
It wasn't until later, in fact, they even
intermarried with indentured servants and
had kids.
This is it wasn't this taboo.
It wasn't until the legal construct of race
was created to fortify racism in and of itself
and create an excuse for it ultimately.
And then after the civil war excuse me, after
after the after the after the civil war, but
before that, the legal construct was formally
formalized, even more so.
So the poor black people could be subservient
to the poor white people to avoid any kind
of upheaval.
And Dr. Martin Luther King wrote about this
eloquently how the birth of racism came to
be.
And it's not what people think it is.
So now you have families that are racists.
They've been racist for generations.
They teach racist values to their kids.
How do you stop that?
Obviously, that take generations, but the
economic foundation is still there.
And I strongly believe the stress of this
strife and groupism, this group antagonism
of our society is to blame.
And if you can get rid of that, to whatever
degree, it's going to have an equivalent positive
effect on people's bigotry.
So to answer your question, I would say to
people, obviously, you need policy shifts
to create more equality.
I am.
I'm for de marketization.
I have gone through the gamut in my mind and
analysis.
I'm not a Marxist and I don't subscribe to
anything socialist in any kind of traditional
sense.
I look at it from a systems science perspective
and what we know in sociology and of course,
efficiency when it comes to systems.
We could go on the tangent of why the system
is unsustainable ecologically and so on.
That's a big part of it as well.
But in terms of this sociology, excuse me,
you have to start giving people what they
need directly.
So you should be in favor of something like
UBI as a stepping stone.
People should literally want there to be ultimately
free food and free transportation and a free
foundation.
There should be that we have the resources
to do that.
So first, people need to understand that and
they need to understand that if we have our
needs supplied now, I'm not talking about
luxuries and excess.
We could still have that as a top tier market
reality.
Right.
But you give people what they need needs that
no one's in poverty anymore.
Then you're going to see these shifts happen.
And people need to understand that that is
not some kind of inhibition of people's freedom
and the propaganda that we have or people
just can't even handle that concept.
We can't even talk about universal health
care in America because someone will inevitably
attribute it to socialism and then think we're
going to be in some gulag eventually because
we have universal health care.
Right.
So you see the point.
But I can't answer that question any kind
of explicit way.
I have plenty of proposals that I've talked
about, and it's obviously education.
But you need to have policy shifts.
And I will say this eventually through a federalization,
which is this more with less phenomenon.
It is to me the the only real economic wealth
that we have.
And it's not wealth in the sense of a physical
good.
It's wealth in the sense of an extremely efficient
process.
Jeremy Rifkin refers it to it as zero marginal
cost in reference to to the current society
where we become so efficient in a given area
where we've created technology that can that
can perform actions such great efficiency,
they become cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
and smaller and smaller and smaller.
You know, the big computer fifty years ago,
we had many tons, took enormous amount of
energy, cost millions of dollars.
Now your cell phone chip is more powerful.
That applied to just about everything in society
economically is where I think localization
and a return to a kind of community driven,
high tech reality where people get off the
grid of normal state control.
I don't mean state in a derogatory way, but
there's the limitations of using a telecom
company, the limitations of having to buy
your food from a major corporation.
I believe if people act accordingly and this
is the kind of stuff I get into at the end
of my my film and Reflections, which begins
what will be the second film.
And I've commented on this in my book.
I don't want to go too much detail, but it's
about getting off the grid of the market system
as fast as we can through localization.
And I'm working on a big lecture in March
describing a platform where people can come
in and start engaging and feel what it's like
to have to have the community resilience and
to engage in networks that don't use money.
Let me talk a little bit.
So this concept of of zero marginal cost is
interesting.
Many people are familiar with the economic
concept of diminishing marginal cost.
So if you imagine building a factory to make
one pair of shoes, that's a huge fixed cost
investment then and then, of course, as you
scale up and you can make more and more shoes
more quickly, the additional cost per pair
of shoes goes down.
But it's still positive.
It's still something.
It's just not as much as previously.
Right.
Talk a little bit about how zero margin.
No cost is possible and in what areas it would
be possible, I think we see it already when
it comes to digital transfer.
I mean, music, while it costs money to create,
even though substantially less than it did
before, can be transferred across the Internet
with zero cost.
You have a comment, excuse me, of the cost
of electricity.
That's it.
Films, obviously, anything in the digital
realm is the easiest example.
You know, it used to be you'd have a big film
projector that we had a DVD.
Now you can have free distribution ultimately.
So that's the easiest example.
But zero marginal cost could apply to state
transportation systems if they were efficiently
created.
So you have automated car systems, you have
even the subway systems that we have.
If if done correctly, it's still going to
cost something, which means ultimately there
can be some kind of labor, some some kind
of resource investment.
But if it's done with the proper efficiency,
there's no reason for the public to have to
submit to pay for it.
And that can be applied to food systems.
Look at the efficiency of vertical farm systems
as as has been researched and as I've also
talked about in the past, the amount of resources
is substantially less, the amount of water
is substantially less, and you could easily
have vertical farm systems localize where
it's so efficient people don't need to pay
for it.
It doesn't mean that there isn't labor.
So there's always got to be some kind of labor.
But think about I use this example.
What if instead of working 40 hours a week,
suddenly I only had to work five, right?
Would they do that if they could get what
they needed without pay?
I think they would.
I think most people, if they were presented
with that, they very much would.
So so with many of these systems, it also
sounds like it's not necessarily about nominal
zero marginal cost, but eliminating waste
makes it a net zero, like for the food system
is a great example where when you look at
how much is left in the fields, because by
the time it gets to the grocery store, it
would be bruised.
And then how much is thrown out by the grocery
store because by the next morning it would
be like the waste elimination could make it
a net zero.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, it's all kind of subjective.
Depends on how you think about labor and energy
that goes into something.
So obviously everything has a, quote, cost
if you put it in the framework of labor and
energy.
But I absolutely I completely agree.
The the inefficiencies of our current system
are so, so extreme because of what we've done.
I mean, the average American food plate moves
about two thousand miles before it makes your
plate, which is obviously that's not the way
an economy would function, especially since
there's plenty of resources and land to localize
food production.
And when you do that, the efficiency increases.
The ultimate element of efficiency has to
do with networking, just like on your cell
phone.
You have all of these things that used to
require tons and tons of apps.
There's a guy named Peter Diamandis and he
he did a calculation that the app potential
on your phone was worth millions of dollars,
say, a number of decades ago, because you
don't need a separate audio player or a separate
film player.
So the networking of things making things
as unified as possible is the ultimate post
scarcity efficiency mechanism.
And that's what we don't do in our society.
We have corporations that are all divided.
Everyone's competing with each other.
You have cell phone companies that are not
sharing in open source.
They're constantly making new little improvements.
They don't know what they're going to do.
They the amount of waste created is staggering
because there's no collaborative environment.
It's a post facto collaboration ultimately,
which doesn't help anything.
So there's a lot to be said on that.
I buy ultimately, my focus these days economically
is on post scarcity.
And if we can achieve now, I'll just comment
on this.
By the way, I did see another interview that
you did a while back on post scarcity.
And it was it was a good interview.
But I noticed that there's a when people speak
about this, they tend to obsess about things
like automation and the potentials.
But really, post scarcity is is an economic
worldview in our current society.
To have deficiency means to be able to make
money for people to be insecure means they're
more likely to go out and buy something in
efficiency.
Sustainability and conservation are the enemies
of this kind of system, because the more problems
there are, the more money can be made.
We have in China, one of the richest men in
the world makes all of his money multibillionaire
off of water bottling.
So it's not good to have clean water if if
you want to make a bunch of money.
Right.
So you have to shift away from that kind of
what effectively is artificial scarcity, creation
that the market system just does.
Naturally, it's just what it's natural incentive
is.
And the people mindset gets shifted by that.
And suddenly people are restricting things.
They don't even know what you have value system
disorders that are created.
So and that's really where I think the root
of the ecological crisis is.
I'll add one more thing to that.
On the small tangent, our entire society is
pushed by consumption.
So, you know, people have to buy things.
They have to create demand.
That demand inspires jobs.
People have the jobs to get money to get purchasing
power.
And then the whole cycle continues.
If you have a reduction of people needing
things for whatever reason, such as durability,
sustainability, confidence, you're going to
harm the economy as we know it.
And that's a very that's a very caustic place
to be as a civilization.
Yeah.
I mean, I think in our next conversation,
we should just focus on environment and and
ecological issues.
But what you're saying reminds me of within
the food system of something Michael Pollan
describes really well, which is that just
our basic and.
Audience are very hard to make, very profitable,
because they're just ingredients, you can't
do much to them.
And that's where this idea of, well, let's
take the corn and will make it inedible in
its in its ingredient form.
But we can grow a ton of it in an acre and
then we can extract it and break it down to
its component parts and create food products
which most people don't even really know they
want.
But we'll create marketing in order to tell
people instead of just buying corn on the
cob.
Here's something made with a corn extract
and that's what you should go.
And I mean, that's that's essentially what
you're describing across multiple industries.
Yeah.
Ultimately, ultimately.
And then you have just the psychological disorder
simultaneously.
When people's values are pushed into a social
circumstances, mean people's values are being
acclimated into a social environment where
people get more and more and they want to
keep up with the Joneses.
I mean, I was one the last person to get a
cell phone.
I really didn't have the motivation to do
so.
But over time, everyone had one.
Everyone like, oh, why can I call you?
Why can't I text you?
And suddenly social inclusion kicks in.
Right.
And that is kind of a virus in our society,
so to speak, where this need for social inclusion,
that's what advertising does.
It manipulates our sense of sociality, making
us feel like we are missing out on something.
And that, of course, is another conversation
in and of itself.
Yeah.
And then when you get this stuff, thanks to
hedonic adaptation, you don't really feel
any better about now having had it because
you're moving to the next thing.
Peter Joseph, founder and of the Zeitgeist
movement, director and writer of the film
Into Reflections.
It's always great to talk to you.
And let's let's do it again.
Let's do it.
Thank you,